guess who's back back again yeah it's me
Hitler the movie opens up at night in
the snowy mountains of Norway where a
girl named Sarah is running for her life
by the looks on her face it is evident
that she is being chased by someone or
something unfortunately as she is about
to reach her cabin she accidentally
trips over and rolls down a hill
injuring herself then all of a sudden
Sarah is attacked by the mysterious
beings resulting in a painful death
elsewhere seven medical students travel
to Oxford Norway for their Easter
holidays after a long journey they
arrive at a cabin in the woods owned by
vegard who is revealed to be Sarah's
boyfriend it turns out Sarah had been
skiing in the mountains near oxfjord and
the group were expecting her to return
to the cabin nonetheless they have a fun
time without her drinking like crazy and
playing trivia games all night later a
blonde girl named Liv heads outside to
relieve herself but as she is about to
commence she is startled by a mysterious
figure moving in the dark Liv holds her
smelly business for the moment and
hurries inside the cabin to inform
everyone of her sighting however no one
is ready to believe her as the group is
contemplating on what to play next
suddenly a mysterious hiker arrives at
the door he wants to drink some coffee
and so the group reluctantly lets him in
after a while the hiker starts to tell
them the dark history of ux Fjord during
World War II a force of German soldiers
named einsatz grupa led by standard
Hitler I hope I don't have to say that
again had invaded and occupied the area
the Nazis abused and tortured the local
people for three whole years near the
end of the war with Germany's upcoming
defeat the soldiers eluded all the
town's valuables however the citizens
staged an uprising and ambushed the
Nazis killing many of them while the
survivors including the general Hitler
were Chase into the mountains because
none of them returned the town's people
had assumed that all of them had frozen
to death because of the harsh cold
conditions but in reality no one knows
what happened to them in the present the
hiker finishes telling his story with a
serious face but the teenagers simply
laugh it off as a fairy tale annoyed he
leaves the cabin and sets up camp
somewhere in the mountains the hiker
then proceeds to have some canned food
when he is suddenly disturbed by a
strange noise outside it appears as if
the beasts from the start of the movie
are back the hiker grabs his rifle and
slowly walks outside his tent to
investigate but in the blink of an eye a
person flashes past him slitting the
hiker's throat he hurries back inside
the tent but doesn't last long as the
killer follows him inside and violently
finishes him off meanwhile vegard is
woken to a ghastly figure placing
something beneath the floorboards of the
cabin believing it to be Sarah calls out
to her but she ignores him and leaves
the cabin scared vegard follows her
outside and shockingly finds her covered
in blood this sends shivers down his
spine but the very next second he
suddenly wakes up revealing that it was
just a nightmare the next morning vegard
decides to set out on a snowmobile to
look for his girlfriend Sarah he bids
farewell to the group and instructs the
alpha guy Martin to return down the
mountain and call for help if he doesn't
return the next day after this vegard
scours the snowy Hills until he spots a
tent in the distance and heads towards
it to investigate but when he reaches
the place he is taken aback after
finding the hiker inside Dead with his
belly cut and his intestines exposed
vegard also finds a track of bloody
Footprints which he starts following
hoping to find Sarah unfortunately just
as he reaches a bit further he falls
into a pit and gets knocked out cold
later that that evening the group back
at the cabin have drinks and blasts some
tunes meanwhile as the fat guy Ireland
looks for some beer beneath the
floorboards he comes across an old
mysterious wooden box upon opening it he
shockingly finds loads of valuables and
golden coins from World War II everyone
is stunned by the discovery and they
decide to split the treasure once
vagarde and Sarah returned to the cabin
in the next scene as the group continues
partying throughout the night Ireland
heads out to take a dump along the way a
golden coin falls out of his pocket and
onto the snow his girlfriend Chris also
accompanies him inside the toilet and
the two end up having coitus ah shy so
ficken a popular German Pastime
meanwhile a creepy looking zombie shows
up outside and picks up the gold coin
this is the same creature that has been
murdering the nearby hikers shortly
after Ireland returns back inside the
cabin while Chris is still inside the
toilet taking a dump all of a sudden she
spots the zombie's face peeking through
a hole and becomes terrified Chris tries
to escape with all her might but the
floor beneath her suddenly collapses and
she is covered in defecation Chris
quickly gets up and limps her way to the
cabin while screaming for help however
the others can't hear her because of the
loud music inside after some agonizing
minutes a girl with dreadlocks Hannah
finally hears the screams and turns off
the music before going outside to check
on her but right before Chris can be
located she is swiftly captured by the
zombie and taken away meanwhile the boys
also become wary that something is
lurking in the dark so they grab a
shotgun and go outside to investigate to
their horror they find Sarah's rucksack
buried in the snow the Dead Snow on the
other hand Hannah finally sees Chris
outside the cabin window but not in the
way she had expected the poor girl's
head has been decapitated and soon she's
split into two oh my god when Liv
notices this she slowly goes to inspect
the window when suddenly a zombie breaks
through the glass and violently pulls
her hair she is about to meet the same
fate as her friend but Hannah arrives in
the neck of time and cuts off Liv's hair
hence saving her now the group finally
realizes that they are being hunted by
lifeless monsters so they start to panic
after regrouping themselves they
barricade all the entrances only to
learn that hundreds of these creatures
have spawned outside their cabin one of
them pokes his hand through the window
and tries opening the door but Hannah
swiftly cuts it off seeing this AirLand
the nerd finally realizes that the
attackers are zombies he urges his
friends to avoid getting bit at all
costs but ironically he is the first one
to do just that as airline's body
freezes by the window some zombies break
through the glass and drag him out they
then torment him mercilessly before
finally finishing him off the group is
left in Terror her after seeing their
friend killed in such fashion So to
avoid meeting the same fate they try
their best to fend off the zombies
fortunately using their sheer willpower
and some luck the remaining four managed
to survive the night the next morning
they decide that Hannah and Liv should
return back down the mountain to get
help while Martin and another guy Roy
stay behind to distract the zombies
elsewhere vegard eventually gains
Consciousness and is able to make it to
the surface he then makes a makeshift
torch and returns back into the cave to
explore it as he Ventures deep into the
creepy Cavern a Nazi flag reveals that
the hiker's story was true and that the
zombies are in fact the missing Nazis to
his horror he also finds Sarah's severed
head alongside several war helmets and
World War II Firearms out of nowhere a
zombie appears from behind and vegard is
thrown out of the cave however he
manages to defeat the zombie by bashing
his head in with his own helmet Vega
guard then drops to the snow and tries
to catch his breath but right then
another zombie Rises up from beneath the
snow and proceeds to attack him vegard
surprisingly defeats this one as well
but the first zombie which he pummeled
into the ground wakes up and rushes
towards him again the battle leaves both
of them hanging off the edge of a cliff
but luckily vegard once again comes out
Victorious after killing the zombie he
manages to grab onto his intestines and
uses them as a rope to climb up in the
process he is bitten in the neck but
vegard's adrenaline doesn't let him
think much about that meanwhile Hannah
and lever seen running for their lives
with hundreds of zombies approaching
them quickly so with no options left
they separate and run in opposite
directions Live is eventually caught by
one of the zombies and it knocks her
unconscious later she slowly awakens
only to find the zombie feasting on her
guts so as a last-ditch effort to kill
the Zombies Liv quickly pulls the pin on
one of the M2 24 stick grenades and
finishes off every being in the area
including herself however the resulting
explosion attracts the attention of the
zombie leader it's a Hitler and so he
sends his troops near the scene on the
other hand Hannah hides up in a tree
while two of the Deads scour the surface
in search of her it appears as if she is
going to remain undetected but right
then a cheeky Crow spots Hannah and
begins making a lot of noise this
exposes her location and as a result one
of the zombies starts to climb the tree
fortunately Hannah uses her quick
thinking and manages to flee the scene
she then leads the zombie to a Cliff's
Edge and breaks the ice causing both of
them to fall down onto the thick snow
none of them are seriously injured but
Hannah is the first one to get up using
this Advantage she bravely kills the
zombie before heading back to search for
her friends back in the cabin Roy and
Martin try their best to secure the
doors but instead set the whole thing on
fire after a Molotov fails to hit a
zombie they try to call for help but the
cops immediately hang up as they don't
believe their crazy story as a last
resort the two exit the burning cabin
and enter a small lost storeroom Shack
in the meantime the guard makes it back
to his snowmobile and uses a fishing
hook to stitch his wounds he then mounts
a machine gun on the vehicle before
heading to rescue his friends on the
other hand Roy and Martin also managed
to find all sorts of tools and equipment
realizing that it is do or die they
decide to gear up and face the dead head
on the two of them arm themselves and
begin to tear up the zombies one after
another vegard also arrives just in time
on his snowmobile and opens fire on the
zombie troops laying waste to all of
them however the dead rise up again for
a second wave and catch vagarde off
guard this time our brave protagonist is
of no match and he quickly shredded to
Pete that was terrible this time our
brave protagonist is of no match as he
is quickly shredded to Pieces when
Martin Witnesses this he becomes
infuriated and goes to town on the
zombies in the midst of the chaos Hannah
arrives but Martin mistakes her for a
zombie and slashes her throat killing
her instantly Martin you dumbass
devastated by what he has done Martin
continues to let out his anger by
murdering all the zombies one by one but
in the process he also gets bitten on
the arm this leaves him with a tough
decision to make either it's him turning
into a zombie or his arm getting cut off
not wanting to become a Nazi he grabs a
chainsaw and amputates his own arm
however his efforts are thrown down the
drain as he is soon bitten in the balls
following this the zombie Captain Hitler
finally shows up and confronts the boys
just as they prepare to take him down
Hitler gives out a big Roar
unleashing an army of zombies from
beneath the snow they quickly finish off
Roy and Hitler retrieves a golden watch
from his pocket when Martin Witnesses
this he realizes that the zombies are
actually in search of their lost
treasure which Ireland had found back in
the cabin so in an attempt to save
himself Martin rushes back to the burnt
down cabin he frantically locates the
wooden box and then hands it over to
Hitler luckily the plan works and the
zombies leave him alone a relieved
Martin then peacefully makes his way
down the mountain and enters a car
however just as he is about to take off
he finds a gold coin on the car floor it
turns out he had secretly pocketed it
back in the cabin the movie ends as
Hitler and his group appear outside the
car ready to murder Martin for their Jew
gold Dusty's rishtig Hitler yeah is me
it's me
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching